for the reaction bromine gas plus
chlorine gas goes to brcl kc is equal to
7.0 at 400 kelvin
if the initial concentration of bromine
is 0.60 molar and the initial
concentration of chlorine is also 0.60
molar our goal is to calculate the
equilibrium concentrations
of br2 cl2 and brcl
to help us find the equilibrium
concentrations we're going to use an ice
table where i stands for the initial
concentration c stands for the change in
concentration and e stands for
equilibrium concentration
for the initial concentrations we have
0.60 molar for bromine point six zero
molar for chlorine and if we assume the
reaction hasn't started yet then we're
going to put a zero in here for our
product brcl
next we think about br2 reacting with
cl2 to form
brcl some of the bromine is going to
react but we don't know how much so
we're going to call that amount x
and we're going to lose some of that
bromine when we form our product so
we're going to write minus x under
bromine in our ice table
next we think about mole ratios in the
balanced equation it's a one to one mole
ratio of bromine to chlorine therefore
if we're losing x for bromine we're also
going to lose x for chlorine so i can
write here minus x under chlorine in the
ice table
when br2 and cl2 react together we lose
our reactants and that means they're
going to gain some of our products to
figure out how much we need to look at
mole ratios so the mole ratio of bromine
to brcl is one to two therefore if we're
losing x for br2 we must be gaining 2x
for brcl so i can go ahead and write
plus 2x under brcl
next let's think about equilibrium
concentrations if the initial
concentration of bromine is 0.6 and
we're losing x the equilibrium
concentration must be
0.60 minus x
and the same thing for chlorine it would
be 0.60
minus x
for brcl we started off with 0 and we
gained 2x therefore at equilibrium the
equilibrium concentration would be equal
to just 2x
the next step is to use the balanced
equation to write an equilibrium
constant expression so we would write kc
is equal to and then we look at our
balanced equation and for our product we
have brcl with the 2 as a coefficient so
kc would be equal to the concentration
of brcl squared
and we're going to divide that by the
concentration of our reactants which
would be br2 so the concentration of br2
raised to the first power because the
coefficient of one times the
concentration of cl2 also raised to the
first power
the concentrations in an equilibrium
constant expression are equilibrium
concentrations therefore we can plug in
the equilibrium concentrations from our
ice table so the equilibrium
concentration for brcl was 2x
the equilibrium concentration for br2
was 0.60 minus x and the same for
chlorine so we can plug that in as well
here we have our equilibrium
concentrations plugged in to our
equilibrium a constant expression and
also kc was equal to 7.0 for this
reaction at 400 kelvin so 7.0 is plugged
in for kc
our goal is to solve for x and i've
rewritten it down here because .60 minus
x times 0.60 minus x is equal to 0.60
minus x squared and if we write it this
way it's a little bit easier to see that
we can solve for x by taking the square
root of both sides so
let's go ahead and take the square root
of both sides and solve for x
taking the square root of both sides
gives us 2.65 is equal to 2x over 0.60
minus x to solve for x we would then
multiply both sides by 0.60 minus x to
give us this and then after a little
more algebra we get 1.59 is equal to
4.65 x so x is equal to 1.59 divided by
4.65 which is equal to
0.34
now that we know that x is equal to 0.34
we can plug that into our ice table and
solve for our equilibrium concentrations
so for the equilibrium concentration of
br2 it's 0.60 minus x so that's 0.60
minus
0.34
which is equal to
0.26 molar so 0.26 molar is the
equilibrium concentration for bromine
for chlorine it'd be the same
calculation 0.60 minus x would be 0.60
minus 0.34 so the equilibrium
concentration of chlorine is also 0.26
molar
for brcl it's 2 times x so that's 2
times
0.34
which is equal to
0.68
molar so 0.68 molar is the equilibrium
concentration for brcl